another race another win for Max
verstappen his 41st victory in Canada
saw him draw level with Formula One
Legend art and Cena at 25 verstappen is
nine years younger than Senna was when
he died in a crash in 1994. although we
should point out there were fewer races
back when Cena was competing the power
tied for fifth in the all-time list but
verstappen could catch a couple more
names before the end of the year Island
Post is just a 10 ahead with 51 wins and
then Sebastian Vettel with 53 but
there's still somewhere to go before he
catches the seven-time Champions Michael
Schumacher in second place with 91
victories and the overall leader Lewis
Hamilton with 103. so plenty of work to
do for verstappen but with the 69 point
lead in the standings he is well on
track to match another of Santa's
achievements in winning a hat trick of
F1 world titles next up the Austrian
Grand Prix in July
[Music]